how about this one king of the nil
[Music]
Marshall Ito who is this who is this F M
is very high rated FM well this is
probably quite quick done can I go for
the judge the opening that yielded
Nakamura a lot of success today coming
back in sting so the the should I go
Bishop d6 are ya sure the stone wall is
a bit dubious when your opponent does
not play g3 has to be sad but
I don't know just felt like playing it
ready for I guess my test line here some
point but I'm really annoyed by the fact
that he's not helping me out here by by
trading on d6 okay I'm gonna go for for
a bit of a ridiculous move here which is
g5 cuz why not okay this is what I was
thinking about whenever he takes I take
with a knife that I got placed a
semi-normal position I'm still worse of
course I mean it's a stone wall and
pretty dubious version of it at that
foot
it's okay I got I got a lot of
experience from this dude mr. Woltz
even mate
a video course on its how to play bad
still most okay this is a bit annoying
he once work f3 rook g3 very quickly
it's actually really annoying
okay what should I do about it I can't
just be lost that cannot be
done some things here that aren't
really to be approved of but I cannot be
lost
but I've no clue what to do okay just
gonna go for this but that is okay so
yeah lack of a better thing to do I
really hate my position now how is that
thread so difficult to deal with that is
just puzzling maybe I'm completely blind
in some way but I couldn't see it
you
you
but I mean I've got a terrible position
here there is no no two ways about that
yeah g4 Ellis's this is very good of
course but I don't think this was the
best way for him like a king h8 and 94
rights gotta get those queens off the
barge it's going to take with a bishop
think Rick a6m5 got to play faster at
some point okay let me try this
94 rookie 4 I've no tricks why don't I
have any tricks why are there no tricks
for me well I don't even get to take of
six this is completely last night
am I getting just so badly crushed this
is not good
playbook the eighth place no my opponent
just isn't putting a foot wrong here Oh
take it maybe that's the one rookie won
some chance maybe he has to take the
night oh this doesn't work he's
collapsed I have to go for mate oh that
didn't work damn it damn it
maybe I can fly you maybe I can flag yes
I'm waiting
hahaha very happy very happy what a
pathetic drunk